you  our town has been dead for six years at  first we blamed the closing of the mine  but something bad had come to destroying  our town even more so you believe it too  something had come to cold rock that was  taking the children the last kid  disappeared two months ago won't be long  before the next one goes just have to go  to work tomorrow yeah can we play  together again when yous at home I  promise  he was gone when the children were  paying the price the children it was  like an ancient legend something from a  book of fairytales Arnold saw but that  feeling didn't last long  well you haven't found him not him  not the others